well joining me in the studio are paul
dales chief uk economist at capital
economics and volasol a personal finance
coach and founder of refined currency
and joining us from leeds is helen
barnard associate director with the
joseph roundtree foundation very good
evening to you all lots to get through
so many uh questions from our viewers
and listeners so let's start first off
with a question from paul who asked this
the big burning political question of
the moment economic one of course as
well why can't we impose bigger taxes on
the multinational companies then use
some of their profits to help alleviate
the burden so many millions of people
asking that to bola
what are your thoughts
i don't necessarily always think that is
the best option because you never know
what they're using some of those profits
for of course they could be reinvesting
it could go back into hiring more staff
so you have to think about it on a
bigger economic scale than just um
alleviate some of the burden
and uh helen of course there's arguments
so many ways
about this if you're if you're with us
helen
i think we've lost or i'm afraid oh
let's let's go to you paul oh there you
are helen um
uh
let me ask you this then about the about
the windfall tax of course the argument
goes doesn't it that um that of course
um it comes the profits come then out of
people's pension funds
to be honest i think it's a bit of a
distraction the issue is not whether the
government has the money they do the
chancellor kept back 10 billion pounds
at the spring statement for tax cuts
later on he has the money the question
is will he use it to help the people who
are facing the greatest hardship i think
whether you then also do a windfall tax
is a separate question it's actually
it's not that's not really about meeting
the cost of living crisis that's a much
a bigger thing about the public finances
and the balance of business taxes but
that's not going to help people put food
on the table
that is the point isn't it but just on
the big picture
paul dales the issue is of course that
it's a one-off i mean you can't visit
the well
continually depending how long this
crisis lasts
no and i think what's interesting here
is that in an ideal situation where
inflation's too high you would have the
government work in the same direction as
the bank of england so the bank of
england is raising interest rates to try
and bring inflation back down you don't
really want the government doling out
loads and loads of money
but
i think helen's right i think the money
is there it's being saved to try and
prime the polls ahead of the next
general election i think it should be
used
to support those people who really need
it and it's more about a distribution of
where the money goes to then rather than
much much more money indeed
i mean we're going to get into more of
that in a moment or two but let's let's
crack on with the questions we're going
to revisit that issue of the windfall
tax this from alex
asks what exactly is a recession this is
going to be back to you then paul is the
economist what exactly is a recession
and what does that actually mean for the
average person well that's two questions
really isn't it because there's a
technical definition of what a recession
is tell us what it is yeah so usually an
economy grows and we measure that
through gross domestic product which
adds up the amount of uh outputs the
economy produces or the amount of money
we spend
and over time that boosts our living
standards it means we can afford to buy
more things a recession is when the
opposite happens where the economy
shrinks and a technical recession by
definition is where it shrinks for two
quarters in a row so a period of six
months and what happens there is that
the living standards of the whole
economy goes backwards so not good news
how it affects the average person really
depends on what happens to unemployment
so usually in a recession unemployment
rises a bit
if you're one of those unlucky people
who you lose your job then your living
standards go back quite some way because
your income declines to nothing just
government benefits um there's going to
be a situation in every recession where
some people are on that that unlucky but
other people keep their jobs so if the
average person is not too bad but if
you're one of the unlucky ones it can be
really really painful okay so it uh has
different effects on different people
obviously um next one came to us online
bola let's see uh what do you make of
this i'm not under pressure to move out
and buy a first home but i do have a
deposit and a dip in place is it
sensible time to buy now or would there
be benefit in waiting six to 12 months
to see how percent potential recession
plays out just that dip that's something
with a mortgage approval isn't it yes so
i'm assuming it's an agreement in
principle agreement yeah
decision decision
yeah i would definitely say that a lot
of people tend to say let's wait six to
12 months but if we look people have
been waiting since 2008 and we have to
be able to say that things aren't going
to get better in six to 12 months in
such a short period of time so if you
don't have to put it off why not look
for a mortgage now i doubt much is going
to change in a year
but paul that can have an effect then
can't it on the housing market if people
are deciding to to wait and see if the
if the prices are going to drop then the
whole market might freeze a bit a bit
like our lights but
let's continue in sound only and hope we
get the lights back on paul just just on
that that and that that applies to a lot
of goods doesn't it people think the
prices are going to fall they stop
buying yeah that's right i mean um
usually when the economy is weak the
housing market is weak as well and that
is probably most likely to happen to
some degree
i think if there's a silver lining here
is that
we at capital economics company i work
for don't think house prices are going
to fall extremely far
as long as
any recession is mild we might not even
get a recession but if it were a mild
one and the laid market stays quite
strong the unemployment stays quite low
then i think the housing market won't be
too badly hit it's a risk and when
people are deciding whether to buy a
home
i think it's dangerous to play the
market i think it's more about your own
personal circumstances your personal
situation and making sure that you are
protected in any eventuality for what
does happen to the housing market
financially
but i think you know
the housing market probably won't be as
good over the next few years as it has
been over the last two um but hopefully
it won't be as weak as we saw after the
global financial crisis helen of course
um so many people not in the the lucky
situation i suppose to to have a deposit
and
a mortgage agreement in place but what's
your view on you know investing sizable
amounts of money in the housing market
right now
i think from the point of view of
day-to-day spending if you're able to
buy and to get a mortgage very often
you'll actually then spend less month to
month than you're having to spend on a
rent
so i mean i would say from a personal
point of view if you can then get into
that situation because it is really
renters who we're seeing under the
greatest pressure at the moment
and who are really struggling to make
ends meet because of the cost of that
rent and it's actually cheaper now to be
a homeowner once you can get over the
deposit than it is to be a renter
okay uh our next question thank you for
that helen i'm going to stay with you
for this
it's from victoria and it asks can free
school meals be extended currently if
you receive working tax credits you
don't qualify can it be changed so all
children in receipt of child benefit can
claim free school meals or reduced price
school meals well really a question for
the government but it would certainly
help wouldn't it helen
yes absolutely and i think particularly
you get a lot of families who are in
work but still on very low incomes and
tend to be excluded from that free
school meal support i think that would
be a great idea alongside actually
getting more cash to people it isn't
either all we also need families to have
money in their pockets to buy essentials
but expanding free school meals to
everybody on universal credit for
instance would make a lot of sense and
would just mean that those children you
would know that they're getting a really
good meal in the middle of the day um
indeed
okay another question on budgeting so
many of these of course coming in to us
during the course of the day this one
from lauren asking can we please find a
way to help people make better choices
with budgeting and food and energy bills
and we've got it up there rather than
scaring everyone about our dire future
most can find ways to cut back that
could in fact be healthier choices
bullet i mean it's it's it's a very good
point um but for some people that there
is a dire future in actual fact the dire
future has already arrived it's a dire
present absolutely i would definitely
suggest budgeting and checking through
your budget regularly i know many people
who do budget but then
it comes to two weeks into their monthly
budget and they don't check it anymore
it's a good time where you need to
reassess what's going on with your money
when it comes to food and shopping maybe
you can look at shopping at cheaper
supermarkets maybe you can look at store
branded products instead and and just
really look at how you're spending also
look spring summer is coming up now's
the time go for a walk outside with your
friends and family go to the go to the
park and just make the most of free
activities at the moment
i mean in terms of the big picture paul
people cutting back that then has an
economic effect if you're if you're
going for a walk in the park instead of
spending money on coffee or something
like that that overall if millions of
people do it has an economic effect
yes that's right it does um
and in one way
this might actually be a good thing for
people's individual situations but in
some way for the overall economy because
we do want inflation to come back down
from the rate of nine percent as was
published today to around two percent
which is what we want and if we can um
tilt the economy so that maybe in the
meantime the economy is not quite as
strong that will go some way to doing it
i don't think it will go all the way
unfortunately i do think interest rates
are going to have to rise a bit further
they're already at one percent on the
bank of england measure they're going to
have to go a bit higher but perhaps the
combination of a slightly weaker economy
slightly higher interest rates should
get inflation back down to two percent
and that will leave us all and the
economy as a whole in a better position
in a year or two time helen your
thoughts on lauren's question
i mean a lot of people are already at
rock bottom is there room to cut back
even more
yeah i mean i think for people on kind
of middle and higher incomes who are
feeling a bit less well-off that's a
great thing to do and as she said it can
be healthier but i think as you say for
people who are on the lowest incomes
doing those kinds of things is already
quite often you know years in their past
you know if you are somebody who can't
afford to eat who's trying to cook baked
beans over a candle which is one story
i've heard
you haven't got anything else to cut
back on you you're already kind of
cutting to the bone in ways that are
damaged is damaging your health
and i think so martin lewis the
money-saving expert said a little while
ago he's out of tools to help people in
that situation it is simply not having
enough money and you can't budget your
way to an adequate income if it's just
not there
very very good point uh to be explored
after we take a short break you're
watching a special question and answer
program on the cost of living crisis do
stay with us we'll be tackling more of
your questions right after the break
with my expert panel
[Music]
this is the
jubilee pudding it's a lemon and swiss
roll amaretti trifle
[Music]
i'm hannah thomas peter and i'm skye's
climate change correspondent
the uk is a world leader in wind power
it's part of the congo basin rainforest
which is such an important ecosystem
it's known as the lungs of africa
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
she doesn't really enjoy speaking to the
press and it wasn't clear right up until
the last moment that she was going to
sit down with me i might be just very
naive but i do believe that change is
possible otherwise we wouldn't be
climate activists
[Music]
i'm confident for the last 30 years we
have known how bad it is
i'm not here to apologize i'm here to
fight for the next step
you can see just the piles and piles of
stuff these sofas and people's desks and
children's books and you can see inside
this home here people trying to
to sort out their home it's just been
devastating
i think everything's at stake the future
of our planet the future of this beauty
around us
the future
of you and me
[Music]
welcome back you're watching a sky news
tonight special program on the cost of
living crisis i've got a panel of
experts here to answer your question
paul dales chief uk economist at capital
economics uh bola solar personal finance
coach and helen barnard associate
director with the joseph roundtree
foundation and we will crack on with a
question from adam who asks about a
windfall tax
how would it work he asks at the moment
we have a supply side issue better
explain that in a moment so surely if
you give people more money to spend it
will just push the price up further and
we'll be back to square one uh that's
going to be for you paul as the
economist to start with anyway a supply
side issue what is that well um
the way prices are set it's to do with
demand and supply um so if people want
to buy something but there's not enough
of it the price goes up or equally
yeah that's exactly what's happened now
really um with energy prices oil and gas
being a prime example
um so the question is really getting the
root of it if you actually give more
people money all you're doing is
boosting demand when you've already got
high inflation is that going to help
um
i would help a lot of people who don't
have much money well that's the issue it
doesn't help the old the whole economy
but then the way i think you should
think about it is there's a hole at the
moment in households finances so on my
estimates i think households real
incomes are going to be something like
20 billion pounds lower this year than
last year so that's a whole so filling
that hole actually doesn't generate a
lot more inflation
you're just getting it back to where it
maybe it should be
so i think with fiscal policy what the
government should be thinking about
really is how to distribute it to the
people who need it and so windful tax
is one way to do that you take away from
the profits of the north sea producers
have actually made a lot of money out of
this current situation and you give it
to the people who really need it who are
really suffering at the moment um i
think that's
a sensible thing to do and it seems like
the chancellor is coming around to that
idea as well he was quite cold on the
idea a few months ago but it seems to be
gaining a bit more momentum and i
wouldn't be surprised to see it happen
either in the summer or perhaps in the
budget in the author okay so let's
follow
through
from what you've just said there paul
with uh baller and helen so you get the
pot of money if you do go for the
windfall tax and then you've got to look
to get it to the right people and that's
actually the
harder part isn't it
is the benefit system the best way
perhaps to help the most hardest hit
bolt yeah
potentially and i think there would have
to be some form of assessment to see who
needs it and in what priority and that
can be the hard part who who exactly is
dealing with that um who do we say gets
gets the benefits first and who doesn't
qualify and by what mark because then
there could be an outrage from those who
don't qualify because they could just
meet the boundary line of it well that's
the problem isn't it there's always
someone the wrong side of the line helen
your thoughts on getting money to the
people that most need it whether it's
from a windfall tax or tax cuts or
whatever
i mean this is actually the easiest part
of this problem because the benefit
system has been carefully engineered to
do all of that finding the right people
you know everyone getting benefits has
been through an assessment they have had
their financial affairs looked into it's
been verified that they have a low
enough income that they need this help
so actually targeting it is very
straightforward you know we have
universal credit we have some of the old
benefits
we can just put it through there and we
can be very sure it's going to get to
the people who are suffering the most
so that's actually you know making the
decision to do it seems to be what's
tricky for the chancellor actually doing
it you know he's very fortunate he has
the perfect tool for the job right in
his hands
got a specific question on that i'm
going to stay with you to kick us off
helen from barry is the government doing
anything to help pensioners and the
disabled who cannot help themselves by
working more i mean it's a very
interesting question affects so many
millions of people in our country
because these are people on fixed
incomes
who can't work or aren't working and so
have no means of affecting their income
by putting in more efforts
absolutely and i think actually we need
to separate those two groups
so what's happened over the last decade
or so is the system of support for
pensioners
has been strengthened has become far far
better and so actually pensioners have
the lowest poverty rates now it started
to go up a bit and that is a problem
around people who are still renting but
for the most part pensioners have a
relatively good system of protection
and to help those who are still
struggling you have pension credit so
you can lift that and get money just to
those pensioners who really need it
that's very different if you look at
working age people who are disabled who
are caring full-time who have very young
children who can't work for those
reasons
the system for them has been eroded over
the last decade or so and has become
totally inadequate so many of those
people i mean four in ten people on
universal credit were already what's
called food insecure
before the pandemic and that's the
government's own figures four in ten
people
couldn't afford to eat properly so it's
those disabled people and others who
can't work but who are working age who
are really at the sharpest end of this
and we need to get more help to those
groups bolly your thoughts on getting
help to those groups and of course in
the middle of this nine percent
inflation well nothing's keeping up with
that not wages not benefits not pensions
it's eroding everyone's income yeah i
agree with helen they need to be
prioritized especially because they
can't some of them they can't work
they're spending more time at home which
means their energy bills are going up
how are we making time for these people
and how are we treating humanity in the
midst of an economic crisis
the
let's look again at the big picture and
this for you paul the bank of england
from dallas predicts inflation to be two
percent by 2024. wow that seems a
distant number now what's this based on
is it another of these predictions that
um turns out to be not worth the paper
it's written on
um well the bank is hoping for two
things here um it's hoping that um
energy prices in global markets so the
oil price natural gas prices don't rise
and in fact fall um as they you know a
bit further they already have done and
that itself takes away
a lot of the
temporary boost to inflation that has
pushed inflation up to this 40-year high
of
nine percent
even if those prices don't fall further
don't rise further that's going to drop
out because the inflation rate is an
annual change um so it's relative to
where prices were a year ago so there is
going to be some natural foreign
inflation here
the second aspect to it is that the bank
is hoping that the
some weakness of the economy caused by
high inflation is actually going to
result in lower inflation further ahead
because if businesses are less confident
in the idea that they can raise their
selling prices because they know
households are not too keen to purchase
things
then that will mean that inflation is
lower further ahead now these things
work in a strange way
can i just throw in there because
there's also one inflation our next
question from blossom says is inflation
only or mainly because of the russia
ukraine war is it many more factors than
that many many more factors for that um
so the results the russian ukraine war
did give energy prices an extra boost
but to put into context before uh the
war in january i was forecasting that
inflation would peak at seven percent
this year i'm now forecast and it will
peak at ten percent in october um so
higher than it was but seven percent is
still higher than it should be so it was
due to a lot of other factors such as
the reopening of global economies after
the pandemic which boost demand for a
lot of products at the same time the
pandemic had limited the supply of a lot
of products so that's why the prices
have gone still and it's still away as i
said don't worry about
people's earnings and benefits some last
question for this section from sam
um bolly you answer this the governments
say they're addressing the cost of
living crisis however it feels like
they're miles behind the problem is
there a risk that future government
intervention will be too little too late
to help people absolutely there's a big
risk that that's going to happen i think
by the time significant change is made
people would have found a way to deal
with the situation or hopefully
inflation will be back down
and
people will be in a better position so i
can assume by 2023 or 2024 they'll say
here's what we can do to help and by
then we'll say thank you very much but
we've now seen the worst of it um so yes
indeed too little too late well listen
thank you all very much indeed for this
section much more to come welcome back
as you can see i'm with my panel of
experts paul dale sabala sol and helen
barnard answering your questions about
the cost of living let's kick off this
section then with michaelas who asks
could we expect the cost of living
crisis to continue
indefinitely or will prices come down
eventually oh michaela if only we had
our crystal ball um
what do you think bola
i think they will come down eventually
yes it can feel like it's been going on
for a while especially as a result of
the pandemic and what it's meant for us
after now everything has reopened but i
think we just need to
really hold on during this period over
the next year or two and
honestly a change will come okay so not
indefinitely you're going for you're
going for a year or two paul big picture
economics again there are as we
discussed in the earlier part there are
so many forces here pushing prices up do
they do they all have to ease a bit or
if is there one big factor that could
change you know i'm thinking for
instance war in europe
yes i mean um
when i think about the cost of living
crisis i define it as you know the
prices we
pay for goods and services rising at a
faster rate than the prices um well our
incomes are rising um so to work out how
long it's going to last you've got to
look at those two things and on our
forecasts i think it won't be until the
middle of next year that inflation comes
back below wage growth so that's when
you might think about the cost of living
crisis starting to end
by that stage it would have been going
on for about two years
which is you know pretty painful to put
that into context though and to put a
slightly positive spin on and not a very
positive story um is after the global
financial crisis real wages the cost of
living crisis back then lasted for six
years
and it happened at a time when the
unemployment rate was over five percent
for all that period um now we've got an
unemployment rate below four percent so
it is painful it's particularly painful
for those people who have a really
personal high inflation rate and
unfortunately a low income or low growth
of income yeah but for the overall
economy it's actually not as painful as
after the global financial crisis helen
i'm going to turn that round for you
because you know we can all make
predictions whether they come true or
not even if it is at the at the short
end of expectations even if it's a year
that is going to hurt so so many people
it is and i think one of the things
that's very worrying is this has
long-term effects so when you have
people who are spending quite often
years
facing serious hardship
that affects mental health their
physical health it affects children's
development
and so what you see are subsequent waves
of problems hitting those families
because you know if you have a serious
depression or anxiety that's triggered
off by this it doesn't go away magically
when the finances start to ease
if you've had a child who spent most of
their childhood seeing their parents
having to go without food for them
the effects of that don't disappear so i
think when you talk to charities you've
got food banks and baby banks and advice
agencies struggling with demand now
you've got mental health charities and
children's charities bracing for the
second wave of the damage that's being
done to people through all this hardship
well helen you've partly answered our
next question but i'll ask you to
expound on that hugely valid and
important point you've been making the
questions from sophie who asks how can
we reduce anxiety and stress that lead
to staff going off sick from work during
this worrying time as you've already
said it's it's not just staff going off
sick there are so many mental and indeed
physical effects
i think what's great about this question
is it points it points out the fact that
there is quite a lot that employers can
do to support their staff
so obviously the first thing if you
possibly can pay
the real living wage if your staff are
able to cover their costs they will be
less stressed they'll give you more
value look at things like the security
of shifts so a lot of people in low paid
work don't know from one week to the
next what shift they're having their
shifts are changed or cancelled at the
last minute that adds enormous stress to
people when they're operating on a very
low budget
so try and get a regular shift pattern
give good notice to people and a lot of
employers have kind of financial
well-being programs so they have benefit
packages you can design those to help
your lowest paid staff with things like
child care costs and transport costs so
there's a lot that employers can do and
of course make sure your lowest paid
staff are getting really good training
to enable them to get better jobs as
those do come up and as an employer you
can really help people break out of this
situation well a lot of practical
suggestions there thanks for those helen
paula this one for you from wayne uh
should we be concerned long term
about pensions i suppose it depends what
kind of pension you have or if you're on
a state pension then
obviously yes because it's not keeping
up with inflation should we be concerned
i think we should i think many of us in
or honestly need to look into creating
our own pension pots these days because
it seems like we are having to retire at
later ages and i don't see that changing
the state pension is quite quite an
archaic concept it was i think it
started in 1908 so we have to look at
what can we do for ourselves to ensure
that we can retire at the age we hope to
and feel safe and secure about the rest
of our lives afterwards and we're now in
an age of kind of part retirement
because you have control of your own
pension pot you don't necessarily have
to fully retire if you are lucky enough
to be in a position to to work part-time
you can get your income half and half or
whichever way you want to split it
absolutely and i know some people who do
that one of my friend's mothers she
works part-time as a midwife and she
she's able to sustain herself through
the proper through her properties and
that's what she uses as her pension
another question i'm going to put this
again to you bola from the personal
finance point of view darren's got a
very specific question darren wants to
buy a used car when is the right time to
take up a new finance agreement now or
wait longer to see finance rates well
with interest rates going up um i'd have
a stab at that darren saying they're
probably likely to go up if you're going
to borrow to to buy it what do you think
polly you're the expert absolutely i
wouldn't wait um i think it can be a bit
of a dangerous game to assume that
waiting means that things will get
better that's not always the case
especially now i would suggest that if
you can look for an apr that's less than
seven percent if you're looking for
getting a car on a finance agreement
but i suppose darren's got a good point
there it's a used car and we've seen
this extraordinary situation where some
used cars cost more than the new version
the the the new model absolutely i've
been looking for a new car sorry a used
car for the last year and it's more
expensive than getting a brand new car
why is that paul of used car prices have
gone up by about i think it's about 27
in the last year in price um so if you
ask me an e-commerce question about
price i'm going to say it's supply
demand it is supply and demand what's
happened is part of the problem during
the pandemic is that
um
there's not been uh adequate supply of
semiconductors which are actually used
in cars quite a lot these days so
production of cars of newscasts hasn't
been there yeah so that means when
people want to buy a new car they can't
and what usually happens is they trade
in their old car so suddenly there's
some car to go on the used car market so
the fact that people aren't buying new
cars means there's not enough used cars
to buy
um so it's just there's nothing
around it um stay with you uh lastly for
this section paul this from tom uh a
very good historical point the last time
inflation ran at 10 we're quoting it
today aren't we was uh 40 years ago 1982
interest rates though he's looked back
into that interest rates were nine
percent they're one percent now tom says
why is the cost of borrowing still so
ridiculously low in 2022 when the
inflation rates are almost similar well
this is a really good question and i
guess what he's alluding to is that
perhaps interest rates are gonna have to
rise to nine percent like they did back
then to bring uh inflation back down um
the good news is i don't think that's
going to happen
the makeup and structure of the economy
is very different to what it was 40
years ago
the interest rate is actually set by
the
balance between savings and investment
it's the price of money so it's the
demand for people holding money against
the supply of money
and what's happened in the last 40 years
is that the desire to save has increased
perhaps as pension reforms mean that we
need to save more ourselves for our own
future and the desire to invest has
decreased
perhaps as people have become a bit more
risk-averse or corporates have decided
to have shorter
investment horizons and longer ones and
what that's done is it's reduced the
price of money so the interest rate has
come down over time so that perfect
interest rate that means the economy is
growing exactly at the pace you want
without generating too much inflation
and with not
not much employment is much lower than
it was so
back in the 1980s it might have been
around
10 it's now much lower maybe
two two and a half percent
um
so
unfortunately i do think interest rates
aren't going to have to rise for anyone
with a mortgage that's going to be a bit
more painful but i don't know they're
going to go to nine percent i am i'm
thinking three three as the max will get
two okay well uh another break coming up
and more questions about inflation in
interest rates you're watching this
special question and answer program
about the cost of living and after the
break we will be asking further
exploring that what can the bank of
england do to bring down inflation
currently standing at nine percent
[Music]
welcome back and with my panel of
experts answering your questions about
the cost of living crisis well let's
continue with what we were discussing
just before the break about the bank of
england interest rates and inflation uh
this is a question from lee who says
other than raising interest rates what
other measures is the bank of england
introducing to bring inflation back down
to its two percent target um
just firstly though uh before we get
directly to lee's question helen i'd
like to get your reaction to that
prediction from paul in the studio
before we took that break that interest
rates could hit something like three
percent now that sounds relatively low
compared to the the size of the
inflation rate nevertheless that would
have a a huge effect on people who've
got borrowings wouldn't it
it would and particularly there are
people on lower incomes who have been
able to buy
and who can be very exposed if their
borrowing costs go up and actually the
protection that used to be in place for
low-income homeowners has become much
weaker so there's a group there who
could face real problems
and of course having to sell and move
and so on can take quite a long time and
in the meantime you can find yourself in
real problems um
and paul just directly on lee's question
apart from raising interest rates what's
the the bank of england doing i mean
what powers does it actually have
there's this
thorny and uh rather inexplicable to the
lay person area of quantitative easing
but uh
go on i'll get inviting us i'll give it
a go so
um interest rates is where the bank of
england changes the price of money to
try and influence the economy in
inflation so if you raise the interest
rates it's more expensive to borrow so
you borrow less you spend less the
economy is weaker inflation comes back
down
the other thing the bank can do is
change the quantity of money so not the
price how much there is of it in the
economy and during the pandemic after
the global financial crisis it did this
by injecting money into the economy
which is called quantitative easing you
can do the reverse of that which is
called quantitative tightening and
that's taking money out of the economy
and the bank actually started doing this
in march it is doing it but it's doing
it a very slow rate on a very slow scale
and um okay toeing the water settings
yeah well i'm just i'm just
interrupting there because our next
question is asked about that as well and
what role does this quantitative easing
in the question is in effect what a role
has it played in ceding inflation to
what extent is the government's massive
expansion of the money supply
contributed to the rise in inflation of
course not just in this country of
course the federal reserve in the united
states put trillions into the economy
yeah um i think it has played a role um
now that's not to say it wasn't
crucially important you know if you go
back a couple of years the economy was
cratering by 20
um during uh the biggest recession we've
had you know in in 100 years during the
covid uh lockdowns and at that point it
was definitely the right policy was to
slash interest rates and to inject as
much money into the economy as possible
to try and support the economy um now
that helped but there's a bit of a
legacy of it because it does mean that
there's still a bit more money around
the system there's a bit more demand
than perhaps there should be right now
so taking some of it away would probably
help bring inflation down um but
unfortunately it's a more it's it's a
blunter tool than interest rates so i
think it's interest rates that's going
to do the as you said that you've got to
do it fairly tentatively i i sense
uh down to the bread and butter question
from tracy uh bola have a look at this
one for those on benefits how come our
benefits
have not increased in line with the cost
of living going up our benefits are
calculated to our needs it just
doesn't make sense
yeah i think it's a shame it just means
that of course they're getting less for
what they can currently afford and
unfortunately it seems like that hasn't
been factored in so potentially right
now it might be worth of course looking
into food banks at the moment that might
be something that people have to look
for but i don't see for example the
government intervening at this point to
help those who are on benefits
helen because of course so the
government reviewed
removed not to very long ago the the
20-pound uplift to universal credits um
the question is how come our benefits
have not increased in line with the cost
of living going up and of course since
then inflation's shot up
yeah so i mean essentially it haven't
gone up because every year the
government is able to choose how they
will raise benefits
and actually this isn't you so if you
look back for eight of the last 10 years
at the point they've had that choice
they have chosen to reduce the value of
some or all benefits
what we've seen is an especially sharp
instance of this because they have
chosen to keep benefits so low that they
are wildly out of step with the cost of
living but of course they can change you
know the government there's a lot of
pressure mounting there's a lot of
people from their own party saying they
should do more the government can step
in and still
raise benefits particularly universal
credit so that it meets the cost of
living and they can do one-off payments
through the benefit system so for those
benefits where they've missed the boat
on that for this year they can actually
make a one-off payment which would
really ease some of the you know the
most extreme hardship which is happening
out there yeah are you listening rishi
sunak um
question boller uh try this for size
this asks about now we've asked a lot
about house prices but so many millions
of people of course renting uh and this
question asks is there anything on offer
to support renters is there something we
can claim to counter rising rent prices
is there anything out there anything
from local authorities for instance
unfortunately nothing i've heard of and
in all honesty it really is down to your
landlord and what they're doing and if
they have empathy on what's going on
currently in the economy
and there isn't much support because
some people may just suggest to you
maybe you move somewhere cheaper if
you're based in london should you leave
london and could you work from home more
for example but unfortunately there
isn't any actual support that i've seen
at the moment
helen it does seem that the landlords
have the weapon but of course there were
protections in place during the pandemic
are they all gone now
well there's been two things that
happened so during the pandemic the
government raised housing benefits which
is the benefit you get to help with your
rent if you're on a low income they
raised that and that really helped but
they then froze it again so for the last
two years it's been frozen and it hasn't
kept up with rising rents
one thing though for individuals who are
worried councils do have what's called
discretionary housing payments so you
can apply to your council and ask if
they can give you a grant essentially to
help with a rent shortfall to help if
you're being hit by the benefit cap now
that's not going to be enough to help
everybody but therefore if there are
individuals listening who are worried
it's definitely worth talking to the
council about that so how do you apply
it's a grant so it's discretionary as
you say the local authorities decide but
you don't have to pay it back
pot of money local authorities have
and they have a fair amount of
discretion over how they use it you know
they can't do anything with it but so if
you basically if you google your council
and discretionary housing payment it
should take you to a page that will tell
you how to apply
the other thing is charities like turn
to us
if you google them they have quite a
long list of grant find it's called
grant finder of lots of charities that
will give grants to people so again you
can click through and see if there's
anything there that could help now you
know it's short term it's not going to
solve the big problem but for people who
are really getting desperate it's very
much worth looking for that and make
sure you're claiming benefits you know a
lot of people don't claim what they're
entitled to go on to the turn to us
benefit calculator make sure if you're
entitled to it you're getting it yeah
yes absolutely listen we're nearly out
of time so we've got a last question and
wow well
john asks
to what extent is brexit a factor in the
rise in prices well let's go to our a
political
economist paul you know how i mean we
we've talked about the myriad factors
national and international you know
brexit is having
an effect on trade of course it is it's
more difficult for some companies
yeah when it comes to inflation i don't
think it's the main factor but i think
it's relevant and is playing a role so
if you look at the inflation rates in
the uk it's nine percent in the euro
zone it's uh seven percent and in the us
it's eight percent so they're all very
high i mean brexit can't have boosted
inflation in the us for example so it's
due to other factors um such as the
sharp rise in energy prices um gas
prices and oil prices specifically
now brexit has played a role in the uk
and i think that's mainly come through
by less inward immigration into the uk
which has reduced the supply of workers
and that means wage growth in the uk is
a bit higher than it would otherwise
have been and that means businesses are
having to pass on more of the rises in
costs because
otherwise they will go out of business
so it is playing a role but it's not the
key role um here in the uk that's global
factors that are pushing it up well
listen thank you all so so much what a
lot of ground we've covered what a lot
of the world we've covered and i hope
we've been able to answer some of your
specific and broad questions my thanks
to paul dales bola sol
and helen barnard thank you so so much
for joining us on the sky news tonight's
special
programme